how long do we have to wait to see mark
wahlberg sporting sully's iconic
mustache and what's up with that prison
scene here's what happens at the end of
uncharted
based on the beloved video game
franchise uncharted serves as an origin
story for rugged adventurer nathan drake
played by tom holland nathan is a street
smart bartender in new york when he's
approached by mark wahlberg's victor
sully sullivan about teaming up to find
the lost gold of ferdinand magellan
sully explains that he was originally
partnered with nate's brother sam who
appeared in uncharted 4 and uncharted
the lost legacy oh i think you're here
because you're your brother well you
know my brother said well nate hasn't
heard from salmon years he can't help
but be intrigued by the prospect of
finding the treasure sam told him about
when he was a child and possibly
discovering what happened to his
long-lost sibling competing with sully
and nate to find the gold is a ruthless
santiago moncada and a deadly mercenary
named braddock however by the time the
entire cast of characters is on a plane
bound for the philippines at the end of
the second act braddock shows her true
colours slitting monkada's throat so she
can collect the treasure herself it's at
this point that she and her henchmen
catch on to the presence of nate sully
and their ally chloe who have stowed
away their fight in the cargo bay leads
to the film's most eye-popping set-piece
in which nate has swept out of the plane
with several large crates when he
finally manages to make it back things
go from bad to worse leading to the
film's final act
nate climbs the boxes of cargo and dives
back into the plane however before he
can settle down for even a second chloe
who is also battling braddock and her
goons and the cargo hold drives into him
and out of the plane in mercado's little
red sports car in an effort to escape
things don't look good for either of
them for a moment but chloe soon reveals
that she has a parachute through a
stroke of good luck she manages to save
herself and nate they make it safely to
the ground but they're in the middle of
the ocean sitting on top of a box of
cargo fortunately they spot a crowded
beach and then find a room for the night
throughout the movie nate reads and
re-reads the postcards his brother sam
sent to him through the years these are
postcards nate now knows some sense
while he was working with sully to find
magellan's gold now that sully has told
him his brother is dead they're more
precious to him than ever as nate looks
over the map and the two crosses that
serve as keys to the location of the
treasure he turns his attention back to
sam's postcards he then thinks of
something that hadn't occurred to him
before sam could have left him a clue to
finding the gold in one of the postcards
in the flashback scene that starts the
movie reminiscent of the flashback from
uncharted 4 sam leaves nate a secret
message when he escapes from the
orphanage where they live young natan
covers a message by shining the flame
from a lighter on the back of the paper
where the message was embedded now nate
uses the same technique on sam's
postcards and discovers his brother did
indeed leave him a hidden message the
invisible ink he finds on one of the
postcards tells him that the crosses can
also serve as a compass
just as sam seemingly intended nate uses
the crosses to find the coordinates of
the treasure now that he knows exactly
where to go to get the gold he has to
decide whether to share the news with
chloe throughout the movie nate has been
quick to trust especially when it comes
to chloe and he's paid the price
repeatedly now however it seems that
nate finally realizes that he can't
trust chloe to stay loyal to him or keep
his best interests at heart so before he
goes to sleep he leaves out a set of
fake coordinates for chloe to find in
case she wakes up before him just as
nate suspected she might chloe takes the
bait when nate wakes up chloe is nowhere
to be found and the fake coordinates are
gone while chloe is off on a wild goose
chase nate takes a boat and speeds out
to the location of the actual
coordinates a cave in the middle of the
ocean however when nate gets there he
discovers that the cave doesn't contain
just one ship but two
nate boards one of magellan's time-worn
ships and starts to explore as he does
sully arrives and is delighted to find
that the ship contains barrels full of
gold between that and the value of the
historical ships sully knows he's in for
quite a payday after all
his treasure that's never been found
unfortunately the celebration is
short-lived because braddock and her
henchmen appear in the cave nate and
sully are vastly outnumbered so they
hide in the ship as braddock takes in
her discovery as they wait presumably
for her to take what she wants and go
nate and sully realized bradak has
something else in mind entirely she has
summoned two large helicopters to fly
the intact boats out of the cave so she
can bring every bit of the treasure back
with her after each helicopter is
attached to one of the ships with ropes
they begin to lift the ships out of the
open ceiling of the cave and start
toward their destination
since the ships are now completely in
braddock's control nate and sully are
going to be revealed eventually so the
two know they're going to have to fight
since braddock and her henchmen are on
the ships as they're being transported
it's not long until the full-on brawl
starts while braddock and her henchmen
don't hesitate to attack nate and sully
once they reveal themselves the duo is
every bit as determined as braddock to
get the treasure
even though the pair know the other ship
is lost to them they do everything they
can to establish control of the ship
they're on this results in a battle
involving clubs guns swords knives fists
and anything else that combatants can
use in the end braddock's henchmen are
vanquished and sully manages to gain
control of the helicopter carrying the
ship however braddock is still standing
and nate turns to face her as the ropes
holding the ship to the helicopter start
to give out
nate and braddock know they don't want
to be on the ship when the ropes break
so they start to climb the ship's masts
and the ropes attached to the helicopter
ultimately whether or not either of them
makes it out of the situation comes down
to sully in the helicopter yet sully
also has his hands on a bag full of gold
which may be more important to him than
anything including nate's life nate
scrambles towards a helicopter and
reaches out his hand to sully but sully
pauses just when it looks like he's
going to let nate fall with the ship
suddenly drops the gold and grabs nate's
hand pulling him to safety the bag of
gold falls into the ocean along with
braddock then the ropes attaching the
ship to the helicopter finally break and
the boat crashes into the sea right on
top of braddock for a glorious moment
the ship floats on the water then as
nate and sully watch from above the ship
crumbles and slowly sinks into the ocean
nate suggests they could still salvage
the treasure from beneath the sea but
sully points out a filipino government
boat is already on the scene there's no
way he and nades could get to the
treasure before they do just when it
looks like they're going to go home
empty-handed nate reveals he stashed
several pieces of gold in his pockets
and a thrilled sully flies them away
while nathan sully's first cinematic
adventure together has ended nate still
doesn't know all the details about what
happened to his brother at one point in
the movie braddock indicates that she
killed him and chloe and sully make it
clear that they both believe sam is dead
however the final few moments of the
film reveal that none of the characters
really know the truth about sam's fate a
scene cuts to a dark prison in a small
cell shrouded in shadows a prisoner with
long unkempt blonde hair is writing a
postcard that looks like those nathan
previously received from his brother
although the camera never gives us a
good look at his face this must be some
beyond that the postcard he's writing
seems to indicate he's been trying to
contact nate for a while but he's not
sure his messages have actually been
getting through following that brief
glimpse the credits roll
finally in a mid credit scene the movie
sets up a potential uncharted sequel
nate is seen meeting with a man with an
eye patch in what looks like a tropical
cafe they are there to make an exchange
the ring nate wears on a strap around
his neck in exchange for a nazi map that
presumably leads to a new treasure just
as it seems like the negotiations are
about to go south and nate is preparing
to fight the man's allies who have him
surrounded sully shows up with a gun and
the parry gain control of the situation
nate grabs the map and throws sully who
is now sporting a mustache and a cigar
sully sniffs a cigar appreciatively as
nate joins him at the door only to show
the man with the eye patch that he's
also taken back his ring as the pair
walk out together nate expresses his
annoyance with sully he was supposed to
arrive the day before however sully
explains he was late because he had a
hard time getting his cat mr whiskers
who he's now carrying in a backpack
through customs as they talk the pair
turn and stop dead in their tracks
whatever they see in front of them seems
to startle them both but before we can
see what it is the sequence cuts and the
rest of the credits unspool
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite stuff are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
you